Nick fournette that's him dude yep
that's it here he is
Perry isn't even a cat who's Barry is
hat who's better-looking you got to see
you in person cat nope Jack you got a
see him in person at the end of the day
this kid is no joke I'm sorry I'm sorry
they're all right it hurts my feelings
I'm bummed out
I'm sorry I know you're upset I don't
blame you he played the same position
there's some [ __ ] going on with you
right now and I get it and I've never
seen you like this I was not [ __ ] back
in college I know you are but Yogi's a
tight end you're in high school will you
play T I didn't you play T
weren't you gonna try to be drafted in
the NFL ta they've maybe I was a full
bag H bag dude but then they made you
Italian
nope okay I don't that's public okay I
don't know about my or teal agent he's
just such a big he's a beast halt halt
turd 6-2 6-2 66 Pollux feel like he was
taller than that I don't know he's
definitely six yeah schools okay Plateau
ha state that's oh you know what I've
seen that man play ball and he's a hell
of a player yeah
Rama thinkin the so big and weirdly
strong like so big I was like well yeah
I mean you obviously are to that all
yeah cuz we're around other comedians
right me and I'm a ginormous man yeah
for an NFL players you're kind of
regular your man but no no no norm norm
well I mean no one's small well well
you'll see heavyweight I'm sure your yes
dude like those guys are huge yeah yeah
he's a stout now you might be you might
be as strong as he is you're very strong
right he's no [ __ ] so I remember
playing in college he's a stud yes girls
at diaries girls beautiful but but
you're you're were you and without being
without right right cut he's he's hot
right
maybe that's the fans what would you say
that would you say cuz I've heard from
Lauren Lando you're you're as strong as
most NFL what would your train does it
say give me his combine numbers what are
you doing to combine numbers yeah go
type in Nick then at the duty plateau
house state that's been so good yeah
he's such a stud
yeah good would you type in combine
numbers I scroll down
well active player in the NFL I mean you
can scroll down from her comments
yeah so I ran a four five eight vertical
29th I jump higher bronze up 95 I did
more than I is that true
yep okay so here's the thing he's way
better at football what did you run what
did you run a 40 in I like the slow turn
for six that's very quick for a man your
size I don't know I tell dick jokes and
it doesn't help athlete for six is no
Charl Orlando right now well are four
six eight by Loren Landau said they're
strong and then there's Brennan shopping
because the strength goes around the
front
she's a strength he said in Cary NC
right he said that you carried a hundred
pounds in each hand for like five
minutes or something and beat all the
lineman okay it's not big doing
everything on his produce but here's the
here's the other your we're strong here
think he's a really really good football
player he's I know who he is he's
phenomenal football dude he's so much
better sure
okay alright alright well dude all right
cross velvet shirt wasn't feeling it but
maybe he's filled now in a
in at us up in a tussle up you talking
about you know you know you guys get he
gets in and goes a bro you know I saw
you looking at my girl don't look at my
girl and gives you a shove around sure
gives you a shovel yeah what about it
you talk about in the contour that
closed bachelor bar you take him into
deep water
well not that deep of water but he might
know I know pop it's me the shallow end
oh really it's me the shallow but he
might be the girl on jaws and you pull
him under what happens he doesn't know
what's going on yet doesn't yeah don't
bring it out dude that's a lie Anansi
cool dude you've got a language you
fluent language
you fluent annoying you can't spoil the
tough guy big athlete phenomenal but
he's a phenomenal football but now but
now and he looks dope there he was the
thing you take a great white out of the
water
so now he's got some problems he can
flap he can flop around Pappas go on
land and sea here's the [ __ ] dude
hey round and hey surf and turf he's
safe return
I'm surf and turf the serpent are
different turn yeah surfing interface
yeah so you're not hearing it be bad in
surf and turf what do you want water
land bro so you're not hearing a beep
out of him hahaha then he goes hey Papa
failed NFL player but you played no game
hurt your feelings nothing at all your
nostrils flare you get a little vein in
your neck no no okay I know what you
know he's such an amazing that yeah when
I even comparable it's okay he was
starting tight in for Ohio State the
biggest football University on the
planet and also my favorite college
outside University Colorado
here's thing Papa Nick takes every boy
here fashion guy like you type is out
tight show out tight jeans are so it
didn't mind his jeans I was in FEM look
at him there he looks like he looks like
he looks like a thicker Aaron Rodgers
right there he looks good there he looks
like there handsome fella he's a
handsome girl is a [ __ ] into did dot
that died she's a 10
she's a 10 listen you don't catch
footballs for the buck guys and not get
your dicks up well there he is I know
he's he's the alpha male that's fine
he's the easy apex alpha I hate this
conversation oh it's a bummer thing hey
he's got a Emmys that make yours look
like your ladies look like you hey is it
Friday at Red Lobster
dudes surf and turf
know that I know that but you tend to
look like he's got a big nipple you tend
to look beneath for a while suck those
no I will stop horny and I'm straight
that was me
hold on you got it Nick you got a tip
there's any other uh
shirtless pics yeah maybe his legs make
your legs look a little bit honestly as
you do this I'm sorry
I [ __ ] I'm embarrassed hey bring his
girl up there in that mocha I'll go that
one go
well she's she's fantastic their kids
gonna be deliciously beautiful hmm
I mean deliciously is terrible thing to
say but I have a seat Chris Hanson style
you wanna bring him up let me see him in
the air let me see him in the vest dude
all pocket is there is more water boy
when I tried to waterboard and didn't do
didn't have such good luck kicking a
water board remember that we couldn't
have those being read inside of
water-borne fool yeah I know we just
couldn't get up on the [ __ ] on the
board no he's a super stunt man we
should time on the show yeah we should
we should and a battle hi Oh state
mainly the thing whiskey brings out the
game both of us doesn't nobody I mean I
sober or drunk I'm I'm into this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]